on pourrait penser qu'il s'agit d'une
visite de chantier classique sauf que
sous les casques ce sont des lycéens et
collégiens qui viennent découvrir la vie
d'un vrai chantier en tôle et en tube
c'est très intéressant moi j'aime bien
bas les fonctionnements comment ça
marche
les constructions les bâtiments souto
l'électricité quoi en tout plus de 160
élèves venus de tout le département
découvre lé métier de couvreur maçon ou
électriciens comme ces collégiens de
bonneval jamais des élèves de 5e dans ce
que leur programme c'est habitat et
ouvrages donc je trouve que c'est
intéressant qui voit vraiment de
l'intérieur les coulisses du bâtiment
moi ça va en tout cas ça m'est jamais
arrivé de visiter des bâtiments donc je
suis content ça comme disait tout le
monde s'est inspiré voilà tu as
peut-être envie plus tard de faire un
métier du bâtiment ou pas du tout même
s'il est difficile d'inspirer des
vocations il est crucial pour la
fédération française du bâtiment de
sensibiliser les jeunes notamment les
troisièmes qui s'orientent après le
brevet est toujours des malheureusement
des clichés sur le bâtiment
la diversité des métiers et méconnus des
jeunes des entreprises de bâtiment
utilise aujourd'hui sur les chantiers
des nouvelles techniques comme sur le
bâtiment sur lequel on est aujourd'hui
qui est en promo prémur donc ça change
du père pains traditionnels et c'est
important de montrer aux jeunes que le
bâtiment c'est plus que les clichés qui
peut avoir par ailleurs car le bâtiment
c'est plus de 200 métiers différents des
métiers qui peine à recruter de la
main-d'oeuvre
après la crise de la construction de
2008 à 2016 en eure-et-loir 6500
personnes travaillent dans le bâtiment